Yeah,
well I was also really
interested at the time,
man,
now in the biological basis of behavior.
Right.
And so,
and,
and in the,
uh,
in the relationship between fundamental
motivational systems and thought because
obviously our thought is grounded in
fundamental motivational systems and your
work on disgust with maybe you can
tell the viewers a little bit about,
was really interesting to me because it
was an emotional system that hadn't been
studied much.
I mean,
you were really one of
the pioneers in the,
in the psychological study of disgust.
Well,
the way to explain it is that Paul Rosin,
my advisor at Penn is the
pioneer in this study of disgust.
And he'd studied it as a food related
emotion and he'd written a bit about it
being a moral emotion.
And I was a graduate student at Penn and
I was interested in morality and I was
reading the Bible and I was reading,
um,
uh,
anthropological accounts of different
countries and different cultures.
And at the time morality was
all about reasoning about harm,
rights and justice.
So Lawrence Kohlberg was the
leading figure in the field.
And because I was looking
at morality across cultures,
uh,
and when you look across cultures,
it's not just about
fairness and Harmon rights,
it's about menstruation and
food taboos and skin lesions.
And it's very physical.
And I was,
you know,
why?
Why does so many societies,
why is it like the normal default way of
being is to somehow bring the body into
morality?
Why is that?
And so I just happened to be at Penn where
the world's expert in disgust was and
I went to talk to them and that started
one of the best collaborations of my
life.
And what it led to is,
is a broadening of the,
of the moral domain.
Basically there's a sort of a western
secular approach that you see in western
philosophers.
I have,
their morality is about
harm and utilitarianism and
let's minimize harm or it's
about rights and principles,
you know,
manual con and a much better way
psychologically I think about morality is
virtue ethics.
It's just a lot of stuff.
It's just we have just a lot
of stuff that we judge on.
And this led me eventually to realize
that people on the left and people on the
right care about different stuff.
Everybody cares about harm and fairness,
but the stuff about keeping your
boundaries around the group,
it'll to wall,
protect the group,
hold the group together,
hate traders.
Um,
you know,
everybody can do that.
But right.
We morality built on these additional
additional foundations of these additional
emotions and foundations.
Um,
so that work on discussed that I was
just beginning to talk about them when we
first met in 1994 led eventually to what
we now call moral foundations theory
and with might with that five or six
colleagues that if you go to your
morals.org,
uh,
you can take our test,
you can learn all about it.
Um,
but it led to the perspective
that ultimately was,
I think the right perspective
as the cultural war was
heating up and as left and
right,
we're essentially becoming
like different countries,
different cultures.